we don't have to clean what do you want
to do with all our extra time we could
make some cold-pressed organic juices we
could switch over to paperless billing
we can floss our teeth we could find out
in my father
I can check email through coffee
insiders do therapy sessions
I can even great points you know I feel
like you were the only one here who
really understands me you know your
robot can't make out with you I don't
want him for his body I like him for his
mind checking stats how's Denver doing
oh no I'm checking out the milk stats
the smart jug tells me all kinds of
vital stuff about the milk expiration
date temperature what farm the milk came
from what percentage cuz you got your
skim milk got 2% you just basic the milk
stuff relax no inconvenience I got my
Bluetooth glove hello hello hello
aren't these USB slippers better than
warming your icy toes on my extremely
athletic calves all right what are we
watching well let me run to the bathroom
first
no oh the blinds oh no no no no those
feet are too adorbs to walk another step
Cindy Crawford you are the flyest cat
and it's all thanks to your smart feeder
isn't it you get the right portions
every time yeah that's where your food
comes from how much for portion control